I guess what it's time for the final
exam where our Fox experts especially
these two compete to show off their
mastery and strange obscure news
knowledge this week's first contestant
goes by the name of Ainsley Earhardt
she's a fox and friends co-host and
author of this book through your eyes
and take heart my child Ainsley Earhardt
make your shell feel happy right if you
do say so yourself
she'll be taking on her colleague and
senior meteorologist and try to lure in
the hall mostly sunny offered she's not
friends but now it's all about winning
Fox and Friends at night it really is
hard now Steve Ducey's co-host well
Friday he probably is because he loved
the morning so much he and breaks the
hour let's start with question number
one are you ready no okay
just give me one normal answer and
rehearsal was yes let me finish the
entire question let me finish all the
choices have you get that right you get
a point if you get it wrong you lose a
point okay red girl blue girl woman
woman let's play best of five wins we
begin with this question okay
multiple choice and that's which
fast-food chain is now selling fire logs
that will make your entire house smell
like their food a chick-fil-a be Arby's
C KFC Jenna see Cassie is KFC right roll
it cashew yeah it's bringing back its
chicken scented fire log it's a limited
edition but not as limited as your love
life if you buy one that's a great line
but Kennedy and it's a great win for
Jess all right we begin with number two
which 2020 candidate fell for an
Internet hoax that this week I
mistakenly believe President Trump had
pardoned Charles Manson you know this is
this multiple choice is there a sound
bite is this multiple choice what the
lady from the lady with the brown hair
that's
pretty and what's her name Janus
Marianne Williamson yes crystal ball yes
Williamson she got slammed on social
media after falling for a fake news
story claiming there was something
sinister about Trump pardoning Charles
Manson even posthumously - nothing Janus
know already gave her the hence we heard
that case about the right answer all
right we go back to multiple choice
South Florida is under attack for an
invasive species invasive species
residents say the animals are running
rampant and destroying their
neighborhoods what kind of animals are
to blame a big Juanes question the
invasive species groundhog or see feral
pigs
I don't know I think it's groundhogs -
one beginning on the weather girl right
I'm not just to lose all I didn't take
the ground on all right so fine check
the judges it's two two minus one never
doing this again Brian please with you
losing a game it's not over yet believe
in yourself okay
question number four this is not
multiple-choice a piece of art featuring
a banana taped to a wall resistors
easily sold in Miami yeah for one
hundred and twenty thousand dollars days
later a man walked up to the artwork and
destroyed it what happened to the banana
Ainsley you broke the rules again go to
Janice familiar forget earlier I didn't
do that
he ate the banana let's check the tape
did you know did you know we told you
about the banana duct-taped to a wall
that artwork sold for an astounding 120
thousand dollars
but then someone got hungry and a
performance artist ate the infamous
banana which is ridiculous and it's just
an expression of excess the people have
too much money and a lack of good sense
that was an art Lauren Williams is
outraged that Janice team is now up
three two - no just for that question
one of these to the wall and see if we
could sell it for the same price like
the sandwich they did that with the
chicken sandwich final question are we
ready this is gonna be your time yeah
these these are worth this is worth 20
points
what no it's not we'll end up with
multiple choice here we go
UK Prime Minister Boris Johnson out
wooly voters ahead of the country's
general election he was seen riding a
bulldozer through a styrofoam wall which
had a big word written across it what
word was it wait
was it a socialism was it B gridlock was
it C malarkey Oh Ainsley be gridlocked
oh let's see
he needs a comb because yesterday he got
onto a bulldozer and bulldoze his way
through a fake brick wall yes
congratulations Ainsley you are zero
zero but you got one right it's very
that means aides Ainsley sadly you came
in second you won congratulations Ann I
get Mary Ann but lady with the brown
hair just give me that one is there
anything in here not yet it's all yours
oh thank you Brian thanks so much for
coming in morning Janice tea no see in a
couple hours
are you gonna stay in the city tonight
can that reveal where I'm staying
security reasons will reveal everything
that's all the time we have each week
and then tune in Thursday so if you can
beat the experts you could be have that
pride and put your chest out and feel
great about yourself let's
a wide shot and he's to apologize for
yelling at me the entire game
[Music]